it is of course um a very sad day
is it not um a great figure
in our national life a genuine war hero
one of the last of that wonderful band
of men and women who served in the last
war
married to the queen for 73 years a
devoted
father grandfather and great-grandfather
and entirely
in his own way a truly remarkable man
yes and the queen of course uh
describing him quite often as her
constant strength
and guide i don't think there is
any doubt about that and she expressed
it very beautifully at uh
i think of one of the golden jubilee
celebrations when she said exactly that
and i think that
he gave her from the very beginning of
their life together great stability
and confidence and he was the absolute
rock and heart of that family
that is no doubt at all and he was a
great character
too wasn't he i don't know whether you
met him on a number of occasions but he
was a
he was a great character and the public
loved him well
um i had the great great honor of
of knowing prince philip for nearly 60
years
and he was much much more than a great
character he was a man of
he had the most wonderful sense of humor
he had great wish he had great charm
he had tremendous authority and he was a
man with no
side whatever what you saw was what
you've got
and um i think when people refer to him
as a character they demean
the very big man he was i mean after all
he
he wrote some very very good books he
was incredibly knowledgeable
he was a great he tremendous knowledge
of technology and engineering
um he with great knowledge of science he
was a great patron of the sciences he
was an environmentalist
he was a painter he was an extraordinary
man
in so many different ways and we really
are going to miss him
we're going to miss him very much and
you referred uh earlier
in the chat to uh to his military
service and it was a serious military
service it was active duty
in the second world war and uh second in
command of a royal navy ship
i mean it was a a serious military
career
it was indeed a very distinguished
military career and
exceptional war service the battle of
matapan
uh he he served with great distinction
in the royal navy was mentioned in
dispatches
and i think that his royal navy
upbringing
and his his life in the navy was really
the background of his life i think it
gave him all many of the very great
qualities
that he had and he was revered by the
men and women of the armed services
in all generations because of his
experience and because of the way that
he
dealt with them i mean he he was such a
a wonderful man to be with and um he was
completely natural
in everything that he did and um i for
one i'm going to
i do feel that i was very very very
privileged to have known him even
slightly
and um i think um i
i like everyone else in this country is
going to find that we miss him very much
indeed
absolutely and so nicholas you said he
was a wonderful man to be with
give us an inkling of what he was
like if you were maybe on your own with
him what was he like as a man what was
he like to be with
well he was completely straightforward
and if you thought you were talking
rubbish he told you um you know this is
the sort of thing about prince philip
they
the papers adore this sort of line that
he kept putting
his foot in it and he was just a
perfectly normal
uh ordinary man ready and he wasn't
going to be anything else that he wasn't
and he was
brought up to call the spay to spay and
i think he was part of a generation
there was a great deal tougher than we
are and he himself had a very tough life
he had a very
very difficult childhood um you know his
military service was a great thing to
him he gave up
um a glittering military career i'm
absolutely in no doubt
that in order uh to be
a permanent consport to the queen and as
the prime minister said
today i thought in a very very moving
address
uh that he was the longest serving
consult of all time
and uh i think that he kind of
is the role model for the job i don't
think anyone has ever had to do such a
thing as he did and he did it with such
distinction with great charm great wick
great humor and he was above all
an unbelievable rock solid rock
and support to the queen who today
our thoughts and prayers must go out to
absolutely and i mean the queen has had
time to prepare for this we've all had
time to prepare for this in a sense but
still
for her just the most enormous loss
well to lose your husband who you much
love
of 73 years is a about a bigger blow as
you could ever sustain
so um we all must think of the queen and
her family
and we were talking just on the the kind
of man he was i was talking to martin
palmer who set up an organization a
conservation
organization with the duke of edinburgh
and he said we had some
blazing rouse sometimes he said and that
was because
he knew what he wanted and he knew what
he wanted to say and he wasn't
frightened of saying it
he said but uh we always resolved in the
end because he was so determined
to get things done well prince philip
was
one of those people in life um of which
there are
many but not often recognized he was a
tremendous doer
and i thought that interview before with
martin was extremely telling i thought
he got him absolutely to a team
but he was a doer and he was impatient
to get stuff done
and he could see her way ahead um i
wrote
i read one of his books not a year ago
called a question of balance which are a
series of essays that he wrote and they
have a sort of
slight theological touch to them and
their visionary and i was incredibly
taken by the power and authority of the
way he
wrote and it was very much the way he
spoke
and he did have this great era of
authority to him
which was difficult to deny and every
now and again there's a good arm or
wrong side of him
probably got it in the neck and a jolly
good thing too